Machine learning has revolutionized a lot of industries today. It can help us
recognize objects  , rank things, even understand what you are saying. But it is
still in its early stage and faces a lot of challenges. Here I will list three
major challenges in machine learning nowadays from research to industry and tell you what
is our current solution to each of them.  The first one is the lack of training data.
Data is at the core of any Machine Learning project. However, it is usually
very hard and expensive to obtain labeled data. How to train a model without
large amount of data is very hot topic today. Transfer learning is one of the
methods to solve this problem. It enables the model to utilize knowledge from
previously learned tasks and applies them to the new related ones.  For example, in
the image classification  task, very few people will train an entire
convolutional neural network from scratch, which usually needs millions of
labelled images. Instead it is common to use the pre-trained models and fine-tuning
them on the target domain.
Self-supervised representation
learning is another way to solve the lack of data problem. It opens up a huge
opportunity for better utilizing large amount of unlabelled data.  Here is a very
famous example in language modeling.
If there is a sentence, but there are some
missing words in it. How can you fill in those missing words.
Well, the idea is to predict the missing words by learning from the past and
future knowledge. The representation of the language is also learned during
this process. Google have used this technique to understand searches better
than ever before, which brings one of the biggest leaps forward in the history of
search. The second challenge is that there are usually some discrepancies
between your training data and production data. Sometimes the model
works well in your prototyping environment, but fails to generalize in
the real world cases.  Let’s see a few examples here. The model may work well
in one country but fail in another due to geographical
differences. The model may work in winter but fail in summer due to seasonal differences.
The model may work well on mobile but fail on desktop due to user behaviour differences
So when you are developing your model. You need to be
very careful when you collect your training data. To make it as close to
your target domain as possible. And keep updating your model once it is outdated.
The last but not the least challenge is about model scalability. It is a big
issue for a lot of projects in industry. As a machine learning scientist, you need to make
sure that the model can run fast enough and the model size is small enough, which
is usually a big challenge for a lot of tasks. One of the possible solutions is to
use Post-training quantization. It is a conversion technique that can reduce
model size. At the same time, it can also improve CPU and hardware accelerator
latency, with little degradation in model accuracy. Thanks for watching, don't
forget to ring the notification bell and
subscribe us.